étrangère
[Musique]
oh
le réfrigérateur s'est éteint et je ne
veux pas prendre de risque d'utiliser la nourriture
que j'avais alors je suis venu ici
pour acheter quelque chose que les enfants
doivent manger
et je sais que ce n'est pas le cas  gâté c'est sûr j'ai
pris du service
j'ai besoin d'eau l'eau est épuisée
partout les gens sont devenus fous à cause de l'
eau euh
j'ai dépensé trop d'argent en courses
ces
derniers jours à cause de ce qui se passe
et donc mon argent est tombé un peu en dessous
donc j'essaie juste d'obtenir
autant d'aide que possible en ce moment
jusqu'à ce que mes fonds reviennent correctement
[Musique]
initialement et que la principale tempête qui a
causé de graves dégâts au Texas
commence maintenant à sortir de l'état du
Texas
qui est  plus d'américains,
je pense que vous connaissez les travailleurs américains
et l'ensemble de l'économie,
d'accord, j'ai quelques mises à jour pour vous tous
au sommet